can you empathize with the plight of
Palestinian people absolutely I mean I I
you know some of the uglier things that
I've ever said in my career are things
that I said very early on when I was 17
18 I started writing syndicated comment
I was 17. I'm now 38. so virtually all
the dumb things I say virtually all many
of the dumb things the plurality of the
dumb things that I've said came from the
ages of I would say 17 to maybe 23. yeah
and they are rooted again in sloppy
thinking I I feel terrible for people
who have lived under the thumb and
currently live under the thumb of Hamas
which is a national terrorist group or
the Palestinian Authority which is a
corrupt oligarchy that steals money from
its people and leaves them in misery or
Islamic Jihad which is an actual
terrorist group and the the basic rule
for the region in my view is if these
groups were willing to make peace with
Israel they would have a state literally
tomorrow and if they are not then there
will be no Bees and it really is that
simple if Israel the the formula that's
typically used has become a bit of a
bumper sticker but it happens to be
factually correct if the Palestinians
put down their guns tomorrow there would
be a state if the Israelis put down
their guns there'd be no Israel